[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24
consacré à l'élection en Géorgie cet
État du sud des États-Unis ou deux
candidats s'affrontent pour le second
tour de la sénatoriale deux candidats
noirs américains un pasteur Raphaël walk
le sénateur sortant soutenu par Joe
Biden et Barack Obama et puis un
champion de football américain orchel
Walker encensé lui par Donald Trump une
campagne clivante très onéreuse on parle
de 400 millions de dollars dépensés et
dont l'enjeu pour Joe Biden est crucial
si le candidat démocrate conserve son
siège au Sénat le camp des moocrate
détiendra 51 sièges à la Chambre haute
contre 49 pour les républicains Jo Biden
pourra donc se targuer d'avoir limité la
casse à la Chambre des Représentants et
d'avoir la majorité au Sénat une
victoire qu'il pourrait valoriser la
Géorgie concentre tous les enjeux
nationaux en jeu démocratique avec
l'accès aux droits de vote des minorités
le clivage Trump versus Biden un scrutin
test avant celui de la présidentielle de
24 on va parler bien sûr de son enjeu
qui sont ces deux challengers quel
impact sur la suite du mandat de Biden
se vote est-il finalement un avant-goût
de la présidentielle de 2024 on en débat
avec mes invités j'ai le plaisir d'avoir
à mes côtés Agnès Trouillet bonsoir vous
êtes maître de conférence à l'Université
Paris Nanterre bienvenue à vous dans le
débat en face de vous Gérald Olivier
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes chercheur
associé à lips éditorialiste à
Atlantico.fr auteur également du blog
France Amérique bienvenue à vous avec
nous également Hélène Kunz bonsoir vous
êtes professeur à l'insec à Paris auteur
de portraits de VIP incroyable
l'incroyable histoire de Kamala Harris
bienvenue également et puis en duplex de
New York nous avons avec nous John Rick
MacArthur bonsoir directeur du mensuel
Harper's Magazine bonsoir John Rick
bonsoir avant dans débattre je vous
propose de faire un point en images sur
ce duel entre le démocrate le pasteur
Raphaël Warnock le sénateur sortant et
le républicain je vous le disais
champion de football américain orchel
Walker ont censé par Donald Trump
les électeurs de Géorgie étaient
nombreux mardi à venir voter pour élire
leur sénateurs une dynamique qui suit
celle de la semaine dernière lors des
votes anticipés je pense simplement que
c'est important c'est un devoir et
surtout en tant que femme et personne de
couleur
signe de l'intérêt pour ce second tour
près de 400 millions de dollars ont été
injectés dans le scrutin le plus cher
des élections de mi-mandat
je veux que l'argent j reste un état
décisif je trouve ça bien que des
donateurs extérieurs déversent de
l'argent chez nous à chaque élection
deux hommes s'affrontent pour le poste
de sénateur de Géorgie
Herschel Walker pour le camp républicain
ancien joueur de football américain
novice en politique et poulains de
Donald Trump contre le pasteur Raphaël
warnokke sénateur démocrate sortant
soutenu par Barack Obama en personne
aucun des candidats n'avait obtenu la
majorité absolue en novembre le résultat
de ce second tour s'annonce décisif pour
le président Biden car en cas de
victoire du candidat worlock les
démocrates vont renforcer leur contrôle
au Sénat avec 51 sièges sur 100 mais en
cas de victoire du candidat Walker les
deux camps seront à égalité 50 sièges
chacun ce qui laisserait aux
républicains la possibilité d'accentuer
leur pouvoir de blocage politique de Joe
Biden
selon des sondages les candidats
seraient au coude à coude quant au
résultat définitifs les Georges vont
devoir s'armer de patience le
dépouillement pourrait prendre plusieurs
jours
Hélène des bases quand même intéressant
pour des téléspectateurs néophytes de
voir deux candidats à froids américains
là vraiment une sorte d'héritier de
Martin Luther King le démocrate qui est
en fait un révérend et puis l'autre donc
qui est le bébé Trump si on peut dire ça
en français l'ancien champion de
football américain à qui en fait est-ce
qu'ils sont aussi clivant que cela par
exemple lecteur noir américain en
Géorgie pour qui va-t-il voter alors je
regrette que la politique est à ce point
racialisée parce que très sincèrement
c'était déjà quelque chose que en 2020
au Sénat depuis le jour J mais
pardonnez-moi mais on peut cyniquement
le camp en face a choisi eux aussi un
homme noir alors c'est bien que nous
avons un système qui permet un peu à
tout le monde de participer voilà dans
les élections c'est ouvert à tous c'est
pas un élite des personnes choisir à
l'avance mais sincèrement monsieur
rocker est très embarrassant comme
candidat il est embarrassant mais il
s'adresse plutôt justement un électorat
blanc oui donc vraiment le lectorat de
Donald Trump plutôt blanc plutôt middle
classe américaine malgré le fait que
justement il soit lui un candidat je
dirais original pour eux mais
embarrassant
mais parce que il est complètement non
qualifié vous savez il peut
éventuellement avoir des valeurs qu'on
se fasse qu'on ne soit pas triste
pourquoi pas mais sincèrement il ne
maîtrise pas les sujets et c'est pour ça
il devait être disqualifié vous savez
quand il passe à la télé ça fait rire
mais c'est terrible je ne comprends pas
pourquoi à ce point il y a ces
personnalités qui sont confuses
complexées incohérente à la cogné ouest
je ne comprends pas pourquoi on choisit
ces personnes là pour mettre devant
c'est quand même extrêmement technique
comme job c'est très serré si j'ai bien
compris Gérald Olivier entre les deux
vous êtes d'accord avec ce que vient de
dire lencoons non je suis pas très
d'accord avec Élodie sur Walker c'est
vrai que c'est un débutant en politique
et précipiter quelqu'un de nulle part à
une campagne sanatoriale c'est pas
forcément lui faire un cadeau maintenant
la politique aux États-Unis n'est pas
réservée à ce que ton client un diplôme
universitaire c'est bien connu et puis
passer à la télé bafouiller et faire
rire ben c'est le cas du président en
place aujourd'hui donc il y a pas de
raison que vous aurez les républicains
ne peuvent pas non plus s'en priver
c'est vrai que c'est très serré pour
répondre à votre première question ce
qui est intéressant ici c'est de
constater et surtout d'insister sur le
fait que le vote noir aux États-Unis
n'appartient à personne et pendant très
longtemps les démocrates ont considéré
que c'était leur chasse gardée
souvenez-vous de Biden pendant la
campagne c'était en 2020 qui disait si
vous ne votez pas pour moi c'est que
vous n'êtes pas noir ce qui était quand
même quelque chose d'assez culotté de sa
part donc là on a un état qui n'est pas
à majorité noir mais la communauté noire
est très importante 30% des inscrits en
Géorgie donc quel que soit le vainqueur
il ne sera pas élu juste par la
communauté noire il faudra
inévitablement qu'il plaise aux blancs
mais je crois qu'ici de la part des
républicains il y avait la volonté
manifeste de montrer que la communauté
noire a le droit de choisir ses
candidats et de ne pas se sentir je
dirais
enfermé dans ce que certains élus je
pense à une jeune femme qui s'appelle
kendas Owen parle de la plantation la
plantation moderne dans le langage de la
communauté noire c'est le parti
démocrate où on fait de vous un assisté
à assister à vie qui va s'en sortir
grâce à l'aide gouvernementale mais qui
n'aura absolument pas le moyen de faire
autre chose que de dépendre de cette
aide et le message républicain depuis
Donald Trump et depuis un certain nombre
d'années c'est qu'il y a aucune raison
que la communauté noire se contente de
cet état là qu'elle peut très bien avoir
sa place entière en passant par d'autres
biais que l'assistana gouvernemental
répondre après je fais réagir Agnès
Trouillet si c'était réellement ça
pourquoi pas mais malheureusement on est
très loin de ça dans la réalité
sachant que dans notre Trump on rien
compris ces motifs pour avoir été
responsable de casting pour ce qu'on dit
là ou encore
allez-y tout à fait
lui qui met en place et il y avait pas
moyen autrement de choisir des candidats
sans que cette personne soit adoubée par
dans notre homme en tout cas
lectoratoires effectivement ne vote plus
forcément démocrates aujourd'hui aux
États-Unis
oui mais votre rend pas possible
vous savez c'était quand même un combat
très longue de pouvoir voter donc on ne
peut pas non plus jeter une vote sur
quelqu'un qui est terriblement non
qualifié en tout cas on voit bien un
estrouille juste à écouter le début de
ce débat que c'est très clivant que
cette campagne est très clivante y
compris donc en Géorgie c'est un swing
States ça aussi il faut l'expliquer aux
téléspectateurs donc une fois démocrate
une fois républicaine même si
effectivement c'est quand même un État
du sud plutôt démocrate républicain
est-ce que finalement le scrutin va
dépendre de la mobilisation des jeunes
des Noirs américains qu'est-ce qui va
être décisif
[Musique]
c'est déjà les chiffres qu'on a en vote
par anticipation de millions de
d'électeurs à peu près un peu moins de 2
millions qui ont déjà voté donc déjà
voté et ça c'est souvent favorable au
camp démocrates donc ça ça peut être un
signe les sondages aussi sont favorisent
le vote en faveur du candidat démocrate
il y a aussi la fracture
urbaine rurale parce que si on regarde
la carte de la Géorgie les zones
urbaines sont bleues profondément bleu
et les autres démocrates Atlanta par
exemple
on a vraiment des zones comme ça bleu et
tout le restait rouge donc tout ce qui
est rural c'est ça votre République
c'est souvent comme ça alors après
effectivement ça peut devenir un état
mauve c'est le résultat de cette
élection va valdéfinir pour revenir sur
l'électorat africain américain
alors 30% de la population enfin vos
tantes sachant que 88% de l'électorat
africain américain voté pour Biden en
2020 combien 88% donc c'est un vote
majoritaire pour pour les démocrates en
Géorgie après il peut y avoir d'autres
facteurs donc
World s'est adressé le pasteur Warner
s'est adressé et allait faire un
meeting à georgiotech University
université de Georgia Tech pour faire
appel aux jeunes justement en les
encourageant à venir voter en mettant en
avant les questions de démocratie de
santé d'urgence c'est un vote urgent et
ça m'a rappelé il faut rappeler que
c'est l'état de naissance de Martin
Luther King et donc il se dit l'héritier
justement où on a l'héritier dans la
mesure où ils prêchent dans l'église ou
après chez le pasteur King donc il y a
aussi cette dimension là qui fait qu'il
faut prendre en compte et qui peut mais
qui ne le donne pas gagnant à tous les
coups malgré tout
souligner quelque chose qui est très
important par rapport à l'époque de
Martin Luther King dont beaucoup se
réclament sans forcément partager ses
valeurs parce que il y a quand même des
choses que Luther King avait dit sur
juger quelqu'un sur le contenu de son
caractère et pas la couleur de sa peau
aujourd'hui les démocrates sont deux
parties de la politique
identitaire où vous êtes d'abord jugé
sur la couleur de votre peau et sur
votre sexe avant de te jugé sur vos
capacités propres et donc là il y a
quand même une perversion du message qui
est assez flagrante et qui pour moi
propose problème aujourd'hui par rapport
à l'héritage de Martin Luther King même
si en effet monsieur warnox se réclame
de cet héritage inévitablement John Rick
vous pouvez peut-être
réagir à ce qu'il vient d'être dit on
évoquait tout de même juste je voulais
redire on évoquait beaucoup le recul de
la démocratie aux États-Unis et au
moment de l'élection de Joe Biddle
lorsqu'on Rafael Warnock ça a été élu
premier Sénator noir en Géorgie tout le
monde a dit ah bah finalement là
démocratie ça marche aux États-Unis
regardez le premier sénateur noir en
Géorgie a été élu à l'époque
les urgences dans le studio on annonce
les urgences de l'incendie excusez-moi
donc vous n'avez pas entendu ça c'était
pardon oui est-ce que oui oui en quoi
vous voulez rappeller la question
cette état de Géorgie était un peu la
preuve que la démocratie américaine
fonctionne au moment où on disait
beaucoup qu'elle était menacée parce que
avant justement ce duel et bien Rafael
Warnock avait été élu il y a deux ans
premier sénateur noir aux États-Unis
est-ce que est-ce que c'est le cas
non non c'est pas le cas ça n'a rien à
voir avec la victoire de la démocratie
c'est encore un référendum sur Trump
évidemment mais ce qui est intéressant
dans cette élection c'est ce sont les
symboles
justement
mon ami la
madame Caunes excusez-moi
avait parlé elle esquive le l'adjectif
que tout le monde utilise pour discuter
les qualifications de EUR show Walker et
c'est franchement les gens disent qu'il
est bête il est stupide il est ignorant
c'est un ancien joueur de football
américain et c'est pas un type lettré du
tout alors ce que ce que disent
maintenant les il a été choisi
finalement par les républicains par le
Parti républicain de Géorgie mais ce que
les les mauvaises langues disent
maintenant au parti républicain c'est
que
nous avons ils ont inversé la critique
contre des démocrates pour favoriser les
Noirs non qualifiées avec ce qu'on
appelle
c'est sans arrêt les républicains
Martels sur cette
se soi-disant horreur démocrate de
choisir toujours un noir un minorité
moins qualifié juste pour soutenir une
politique identitaire ou la justesse la
justice raciale mais là les républicains
ont choisi un type vraiment vraiment
stupide parce qu'il est mais uniquement
parce qu'il est noir alors ça c'est
c'est devenu la caricature dans les
républicains
critiquent les démocrates il peut gagner
donc le choix est peut-être
oui pour gagner parce que oui oui Trump
oui oui et les miracles se produisent
non il te temps en temps mais mais quand
même c'est pas un choix entre deux noirs
exactement c'est un choix entre un type
vraiment illettré un type un peu un peu
un peu franchement les traits plus
éduqués plus éduqué alors celui qui est
le plus éduqué un des deux Rafael
worlock a été soutenu par Barack Obama
on va justement écouter Barack Obama qui
est venu le soutenir le premier décembre
dernier
si je ne suis pas fatigué vous ne pouvez
pas être fatigué
si les hommes et les femmes qui ont dû
endurer la dureté de la discrimination
la douleur des cours reçus n'était pas
fatiguée
si les pionniers qui ont dû mener ces
combats les plus durs
pour les droits syndicaux le droit de
vote les droits des homosexuels et les
droits des femmes ne sont pas fatigués
vous ne pouvez pas être fatigué
donc là il a une écoute on voit bien
qu'il met en avant justement le droit
des femmes le droit alors il a pas dit
le droit des minorités mais le droit des
femmes le droit des il y a quand même
effectivement toute cette cette
campagne en faveur des minorités et des
droits des femmes en particulier y
compris en Géorgie
quand même en tout cas je pense que
c'est quand même que
au joueur d'aujourd'hui nous sommes
toujours peu représenter donc il faut
pas avoir des personnes non qualifiées
comme disait le confrères on ne peut pas
avoir des personnes bêtes le fait qu'il
soit ancien joueur de foot foot
américain pourquoi pas là dans l'idée
c'est plutôt bon tout à chaque vous
expliquer qu'il a des chances de gagner
c'est juste parce qu'il est assez Donald
Trump
qui dit que les républicains tout à
l'heure honneur ils savent voter pour le
républicain quel que soit alors que du
côté démocrate il y a beaucoup beaucoup
ou les réaction peut-être Gérald Olivier
dans votre question et dans votre
présentation c'est à dire que la Géorgie
est ce que vous avez appelé un swing
state donc c'est un état clé un état
décisif et un état-clé c'est par
définition un état dans le lectorat est
divisé presque à 55 ans et où les
élections inévitablement se jouent à la
marge et et parfois à une infime marge
donc monsieur Warnock est là parce que
en 2020 en fait en 2021 c'était il a
gagné déjà au troisième tour contre un
autre candidat républicain avec quelques
centaines ou quelques milliers de voix
d'avance c'était déjà très serré là il y
a eu une élection gouvernatoriale comme
vous le rappeliez et le candidat
républicain a gagné très largement et en
toute logique si tous les républicains
votaient comme Madame Kunz vient de le
dire nous ne serions pas à débattre de
cette élection aujourd'hui parce que
Monsieur Walker aurait été élu parce
qu'il est vrai que tous les électeurs
qui ont voté pour camp avait voté pour
Walker aurait gagné donc finalement
j'irai pas dire qu'il est bête moi je
respecte les gens quels qu'ils soient
quel que soit leur ambition donc je
n'aime pas de je n'irai jamais de dire à
quelqu'un il est bête il est il manque
d'éducation il est peut-être il a
peut-être des difficultés des fois dans
son élocution mais il est pas plus bête
qu'un autre et il a un parcours qui est
tout aussi honorable que d'autres donc
je vais pas du tout le juger là-dessus
par contre c'est vrai que c'est un
novice en politique c'est quelqu'un qui
a des problèmes parfois à s'exprimer qui
manifestement n'a pas une éducation
universitaire ni même une éducation qui
a été poussée ça ne lui retire aucun
mérite et pour moi ça ne présume
aucunement de ses capacités à remplir
son job de sénateur rappelons que les
démocrates ont élu en Pennsylvanie à
monsieur qui s'appelle John Federman qui
a souffert d'un AVC il y a pas plus de
six mois qui est incapable d'aligner
trois mots et dont tout le monde sait
très bien qu'il ne sera pas capable de
gérer son poste et qu'il aura qui le
feront à sa place donc la question de la
compétence être soulevée pour Monsieur
Walker quand elle ne l'a pas été pour
d'autres candidats je trouve ça un tout
petit peu comment dirais-je
ne peut être que compétent parce que il
connaît le job il était le question il a
subi il a il a handicap aujourd'hui qui
n'avait pas en début de campagne et pour
moi fait qu'il n'est plus en mesure il a
la capacité l'intelligence les qualités
il est plus en mesure d'assumer ce job
il aurait dû se retirer on aurait dû
mettre un candidat à sa place mais il
est resté et donc les électeurs
démocrates ont voté en toute discipline
pour quelqu'un dont ils savent très bien
qu'il n'a plus la capacité mentale
d'assumer le job
ne leur veux pas mais c'est en fait elle
a pu faire des entretiens il a pu être
face aux journalistes il a su répondre
question et en toute modestie il a pu
dire oui j'ai un AVC et je m'en sors
donc pardonnez-moi c'est extrêmement
différent que notre choix c'est
quelqu'un qui ne comprend pas
comprendre pas et ce qui est très
regrettable
c'est que on est devenu dans une heure
ne pas connaître les choses parce que
Monsieur
c'est le parti républicain de Géorgie
qui a décidé du candidat c'est pas
Donald Trump
c'est le candidat de Donald Trump tout
nu même il a été soutenu par des jeunes
mais pas choisi forcément mais sous peu
en tout cas est-ce qu'il est-ce qu'il
risque pas justement de de le payer sa
gnestroyer d'être finalement quand même
considéré comme le candidat soutenu par
Donald Trump maintenant que Donald Trump
se fait un tout petit peu plus discret
justement ces candidats n'ont pas gagné
enfin une grande majorité d'entre eux
n'a pas gagné
les candidats soutenus par Trump ont
vraiment
échouer et donc ça va être un petit peu
un test pour Trump
la réussite ou non de Walker je pense
qu'à partir de là ça pourrait
effectivement pousser
certains négateur à se débarrasser de
cette étiquette qui commence à perdre un
petit peu de sang de sa dorure et
peut-être aller vers un point de bascule
ou en tout cas l'inféodation à Trump va
peut-être
se trouver réduite on va voir à la suite
de cette sélection ce sera effectivement
un coin intéressant à John Rick sill
gagne effectivement Walker c'est vrai
qu'il y a alors bon Géral l'olivier dit
il a pas été choisi par Donald Trump
mais il est soutenu par Donald Trump et
alors même si Donald Trump a été plus
discret ces derniers temps s'il gagne il
sera quand même considéré je veux dire
ça va redorer effectivement un peu
Donald Trump qui est un petit peu dont
les candidats en fait n'ont pas gagné
vraiment
c'est primordial c'était tout tout ce
qui compte chez les Américains
maintenant et dans le parti démocrate et
de vous prendre pour anti trompe Walker
et pro Trump il a été pas choisi
exactement par Trump mais il a il a il a
bien sûr
profiter du soutien de Donald Trump
parce qu'il y a d'autres
candidats peut-être moins plus qualifié
entre guillemets que un seul Walker pour
être sénateur mais ils n'ont pas le
soutien du Grand Donald alors si Walker
perd
j'ai beaucoup de gens vont dire bon
prononcer la morte la mort de Donald
Trump et la victoire de la de la raison
à mon avis Trump est loin d'être fini
mais c'est c'est encore un référendum
sur 30 et le Trump et c'est pas un choix
entre deux candidats égaux c'est pas
mauvais choix c'était
les candidats jouent les rôles
symboliques et malheureusement chez nous
les problèmes dans la société ne sont
pas symboles et ils sont réels ils sont
cassants et vraiment nous avons il va
falloir faire face l'année prochaine à
des
à des à des enjeux très importants à des
à des crises économiques très
importantes qui n'aura qu'il sera qu'ils
seront pas résolus par la victoire des
protéinte ou des antitrans le Sénat en
tout cas pour revenir justement c'est la
chambre la plus importante la chambre
haute si les démocrates donc obtiennent
51 voies il siègeront donc dans les
commissions essentielles Joe Biden a
fait campagne ça on l'a vu auprès de
Warner comme Barack Obama notamment sur
sa loi anti-inflation sans ni fléchen
reduction act on va écouter Joe Biden
l'inflation notamment dans les épiceries
commencent à ralentir dieu merci les
prix des vêtements des téléviseurs et
des appareils électroménagers sont
également en baisse
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour la période
des fêtes de Noël il va falloir du temps
pour ramener l'inflation à un niveau
normal tout en maintenant l'emploi et
nous pourrions essuyer des revers en
cours de route mais c'est notre priorité
je vous promets c'est notre priorité
de Joe Biden et en ce moment on a
l'impression qu'il a un peu le vent en
poupe est-ce que c'est le cas oh je
pense que ça tient bien et il est assez
bon je vais dire légitime pour se
représenter surtout parce que Trump a
fait ça fait savoir que lui-même alors
que toutefois pendant le premier
élection Baden a dit que il va pas
chercher un deuxième mandat donc il
voulait un peu là dessus mais c'est très
in pour l'instant c'est va se présenter
ou pas mais en tout cas ça n'est pas
exclu ce n'est pas en fait il y a des
revenus dans la pretty démocrate par
exemple l'idée que vous savez les
premières étapes où on met les candidats
ça sera plus ça va être Caroline du Sud
ça ils ont changé les primaires ils ont
changé en fait un certain nombre d'État
oui donc on entend que effectivement
s'il y a des primaires ça veut dire que
lui-même n'est pas candidat mais c'est
dans une soucis d'être plus
représentative je pense pas que c'est
pour
les actions c'est juste pour que en plus
grand nombre de personnes plus
représentatifs et leurs possibilités de
mieux choisir les candidats au démarrage
des Gérald Olivier c'est vrai qu'on a
l'impression que finalement Joe Biden
avec son inflation acte plus un certain
nombre de plan de relance qu'il a mis en
place
un certain nombre finalement de lois
transpartisanes il s'en sort plutôt
généreuse en tout cas il y a eu un
certain nombre de votes républicains
c'est pour ça que je dis transpartisan
mais bon
en voilà pour quelqu'un qui n'a jamais
été très populaire depuis le début
d'ailleurs est-ce qu'il s'en sort
finalement pas mal une loi
anti-inflation qui dépense 400 milliards
de dollars en subvention inutile je sais
pas si elle lutte beaucoup contre
l'inflation
et surtout elle a elle a un terme qui
est totalement mislining on va dire en
anglais excusez-moi dans de faire un
anglicisme elle est trompeuse dans son
nom parce qu'elle elle ne traitera pas
de l'inflation mais
deux choses pour répondre à la question
concernant le cas le cas jobiden il faut
aussi comprendre qu'il ne peut pas ne
pas dire qui sera pas candidat il ne
peut pas dire qu'il ne sera pas candidat
il est obligé de rester dans la
perspective où il fera un deuxième
mandat sinon il devient de par lui-même
ce qu'on appelle un canard boiteux parce
que si on sait que Biden ça s'arrête fin
2024 et qu'en 2025 il sera plus là on
passera déjà à la personne suivante et
pourquoi donc la deuxième moitié de son
une deuxième moitié de mandat quand on
sait que vous serez pas là après vous
comptez beaucoup moins en président
surtout si vous n'avez plus la majorité
à la Chambre
il n'a plus c'est vrai que le Sénat les
démocrates ne contiennent déjà vous
l'avez souligné ils ont 50 sièges et
avec kamalaris ça fait 51 en cas de
Voltaire
égalités
ce sera déjà un résolu c'est vrai mais
pour pour un dernier petit point parmi
les ceux que vous évoquez c'est vrai que
le Parti démocrate a donc déplacé le
lieu de la première primaire qui ne sera
plus dans les yoah mais qui sera en
Caroline du Sud
c'est le premier état à remporté par
Biden en 2020 sans cet état là il était
terminé parce qu'il avait perdu la Hawa
il était loin dans le New Hamshire il
était dans les oubliettes il a été sorti
du trou par un certain Monsieur Jim
cliburn qui est un représentant noir de
Géorgie et après cela il a eu ce qu'on
appelle l'élan avec lui qu'il l'a porté
vers la nomination donc choisir comme
première état de la primaire celui ou
Joe Biden a gagné c'est plus que
symbolique et pour moi ça va dans le
sens où il a tout à fait l'intention se
représentés
a priori Joe Biden il a 80 ans alors on
a beaucoup parlé de son âge mais enfin
82 il a intérêt à se représenter pour
les raisons que vous venez d'évoquer
c'est à dire qu'on porte pas quelqu'un
qui qui va partir et justement à propos
de de Biden et des politiques de Biden
je voudrais revenir sur wordox auquel on
reproche de voter avec Biden qui a quand
même une cote de popularité passée autre
que ça en ce moment donc pour les
radicaux du parti du Parti démocrate
c'est voilà c'est un reproche à 96%
selon team Scott sénateur de Caroline du
Sud justement
worlock a voté avec Biden mais alors que
Biden est toujours donc vous dit
toujours un populaire toujours aussi
impopulaire c'est pas il est pas très
haut dans les sondages donc on lui
reproche ça et
on lui reproche aussi en fait d'être
en fait je voudrais revenir un petit peu
sur peut-être si je peux me permettre
sur ces deux candidats noirs qui sont
pas exactement équivalents puisque
justement on en a un qui est déjà en
poste qui est un des plus grands
communicants du Sénat puisqu'il est
de l'autre côté on a quelqu'un qui
insiste sur les sur les problèmes
civilisations les guerres culturelles
etc donc on a des des thèmes de campagne
qui sont complètement différents mais
qui reflètent tout à fait les les thèmes
de campagne entre Trump et Biden
finalement John Rick est-ce que
justement vous pensez vous que Joe Biden
va se représenter est-ce que
effectivement le fait d'avoir choisi la
Caroline du Sud comme premier état pour
les primaires est un signe qu'il va
effectivement se représenter
oui je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
mon collègue français elle a mais juste
une précision clyber le représentant
clyberg il est représentant de la
Caroline du Sud pas du de la chirurgie
excusez-moi et mais
a déjà
à cause de cette annonce qui a qui a été
fait par le Comité National ça fait part
de la du projet du Comité national de
démocratique
le camp burnison a tout de suite
riposter parce que eux ils comprennent
très bien que si Sanders et c'est
toujours possible se présente en
il a des avantages si les premiers les
premiers primaires sont dans la loi et
le noir dans le Nord dans les États à
milouest et Nord et nordiste donc déjà
on peut voir le début d'un d'un combat
d'une lutte dans les primaires entre
soit Sanders lui-même ou un candidat qui
travaille au nom de qui se présente se
présente au nom de Sanders et bye qui se
présente au nom des classiques du Parti
démocrate la machine démocrate dont on
va se retrouver configuration qu'on
avait auparavant finalement
peut-être peut-être et c'est c'est
intéressant parce que c'est un dehors ce
n'est pas jeune non plus il est plus
peut-être plus élégant plus élégant que
bad dans ses paroles dans ces constats
mais il est quand même très très vieux
il a déjà 82 ans je pense donc donc
c'est grave c'est grave si la lutte
entre démocrate est entre deux types
très très vieux ça donnera l'occasion un
jeune un plus jeune républicain comme du
Saintes la possibilité d'attaquer sur
juste sur le la question de l'âge du
président est-ce que le président va
survivre son manque à la fin de son
mandat
de pourrait en profiter prendre des
senti ça donc qui est le gouverneur de
Floride et qui est donc le grand rival
de Donald Trump et Donald Trump qui
n'est pas tout jeune non plus lui il a
annoncé sa candidature clairement
ma candidature pour la présidence des
États-Unis
bon ça c'était le 15 novembre 15
novembre
effectivement ça avait un peu surpris
tout le monde tout en surprenant pas
vraiment mais là effectivement on est
quand même Gérard de Lyon on se retrouve
aussi dans un conflit de génération
finalement alors au sein des démocrates
effectivement ils ont tous un âge moyen
pas loin de 80 mais alors là
effectivement Ron De Santis beaucoup
plus jeune qui devient le favori des
médias conservateurs et donc un vrai
challenger de Donald Trump
la République 1 autre que conservateur
parce que je les conservateurs peut-être
que encore que De Santis a une très très
bonne cote auprès d'eux mais il est
beaucoup plus unificateur auprès du
parti vous avez différentes tendances
malgré tout au sein du parti républicain
et les conservateurs ne sont pas la
seule elle qui domine il y en a d'autres
un petit peu plus modérée plus ouverte
mais enfin en tout cas la Fox New York
Post enfin les journaux de rock Awards
mais ils se sont retournés contre Trump
et répondre à une question que vous
posiez un petit peu plus tôt le perdant
de de ces mythermes c'est déjà Trump
quel que soit le résultat de la Géorgie
un petit peu parce honnêtement on ne
s'attend pas à ce qu'il gagne il ne part
absolument pas favori dans les sondages
il a deux points de retard il a tout les
handicaps qui ont été cités autour de
cette table et qui d'une certaine façon
sans réel même si personnellement je
n'utiliserai pas les termes qui auraient
été employés donc si work gagnent ce
sera une surprise parce qu'il est
véritablement ce qu'on appelle en
anglais under dog c'est à dire vraiment
le le challengeur mais concernant la
présidentielle c'est vrai que Donald
Trump a été pointé du doigt comme
responsable des mauvais résultats
républicains compte tenu de l'état du
pays compte tenu de la tradition qui
veut commitums le parti au pouvoir soit
systématiquement sanctionné les
démocrates s'en sont très très bien
sortis et d'une certaine façon les
républicains sont très heureux d'avoir
réussi à remporter une très très infime
majorité à la Chambre des Représentants
parce que ça leur donne un pouvoir de
blocage qu'il n'avaient pas et qui
évidemment est incomplet puisqu'il ne
contrôle pas le Sénat et on blâme Trump
pour ses résultats et en fait je dirais
qu'il faut prendre le cette explication
un petit peu dans les deux sens
c'est-à-dire que ce qui a fonctionné
pour moi dans la campagne comme le dit
très bien monsieur Rick MacArthur c'est
que ça a été un référendum sur Trump un
de plus et que la campagne des
démocrates a consisté justement à
effrayer l'ensemble de lectorat sur le
risque représenté par Donald Trump
risque à la démocratie américaine à
travers une commission sur les
événements du 6 janvier qui est resté en
filigrane finalement est assez n'a pas
convaincu en tout cas les partisans de
Trump cette commission justement qui
accuse les partenaires restent les
partisans s'adressait pas aux partisans
il s'adressait à l'autre camp il s'agit
de mobiliser l'autre camp contre Trump
Trump Biden n'a pas gagné en 2020 c'est
Trump qui a perdu parce que ça a été un
référendum contre lui le candidat
adverse est en bas Eden s'est retrouvé
avec le nombre de voix qu'il a eu mais
l'élection de 2020 était déjà un
référendum contre Trump après 4 ans de
présidents on est toujours dans la même
dynamique ce que disait et le droit
l'avortement est-ce qu'il a porté quand
même pendant ces élections ces dernières
élections je pense que cette question
apaisait beaucoup moins que les
questions de la demeure que c'est
elle-même sur l'idée que on ne peut pas
entendre qu'il y a des candidats qui
disent voter pour moi
l'élection savoyarde on compte ou par
les votes encore cela oui c'est terrible
quand on parle par exemple la commission
sur le 6 janvier ce n'est pas du tout
commenter de la même manière selon les
chaînes si vous écoutez Fox c'est pas
une commission parlementaire qui se
déroule devant le Congrès etc c'est
vraiment ce sont nos compatriotes il y
avait prod ils essaient de rectifier une
fois que vous voyez donc on a vraiment
du mal à être d'accord sur quel est le
fondement du problème donc si vous
voulez
démocratie que par exemple le droit à
l'avortement qui a été vraiment tout de
même utilisé dans cette campagne par les
démocrates c'était utilisé tout à fait
il y avait beaucoup de référendum est
apparita ce qui conduit injustice pour
les femmes mais bon c'est quand même le
débat public qui est toujours là il y a
moyen de rectifier qui sont toujours en
place
excusez-moi je pense que les deux ont
joué jusqu'à un certain point parce que
malgré tout même si la la Cour suprême
n'a pas interdit l'avortement et elle a
simplement rendu le droit aux états de
le gérer individuellement étape par état
c'était une décision symbolique qui a
surprise pas mal de gens et choqué un
petit peu donc elle a contribué à
mobiliser le camp adverse mais la
campagne pour dénoncer je dirais la
menace sur la démocratie supposée
représentée par les supporters de Donald
Trump elle a aussi porté ça a été les
discours de Biden souvenez-vous des
discours de Baden au mois de septembre
et elle a mi-octobre où il vous dit les
candidats Maga menacent démocratie
américaine ce qui t'a dit jamais entendu
de la part d'un président qui
disqualifie le camp adverse parce que
sur le fond c'est un discours qui est
soutenable intenable inacceptable
c'est-à-dire qu'on ne peut pas dire que
si les gens votent dans un sens ils
menace sa démocratie comment le vote
pourrait-il menacer la démocratie il
faut qu'on l'explique ça j'aimerais que
vous êtes vous êtes d'accord parce que
on a l'impression que c'est
oui oui
allez-y je suis un peu d'accord pas mais
ils ont ils sont allés plus loin ils
sont allés plus loin que ça monsieur le
le ils ont nettement accusé les les
républiques les beaucoup de candidats
républicains d'être fasciste je
n'exagère pas on disait sans arrêt voter
contre le fascisme et si vous votez pour
un certain républicains dans l'état de
wiscard c'est nous rendre Johnson vous
votez carrément pour un fasciste qui qui
va supprimer la démocratie alors c'est
extraordinaire ce qui s'est ce qui s'est
produit pendant les mi-mandat une un
débat complément tordu sur la démocratie
et je reviens à cette idée que Trump
c'est toujours le ou le nom avec Trump
c'est un référendum on vote oui ou non
au sujet de Trump ça c'est pas la
démocratie
[Musique]
son ni l'un ni l'autre des grands
esprits oui excusez-moi si Donald Trump
est concurrencé par Ron De Santis
justement la prochaine une primaire
peut-être au sein du parti républicain
là il y aura plus de pour ou contre
Dorian Trump on va sortir de la logique
référendum pour ou contre Trump
qui va qui fait de son mieux pour imiter
la politique de Trump sans être Trump va
pas ne va pas offrir une politique un
programme différent vraiment nettement
différent que que celui de Trump c'est
déjà garanti il a déjà dit c'est un
imitateur il essaie de jouer Trump sans
les bêtises sans les conneries etc un
type plus posé plus respectable etc donc
ça reste quand même dur aussi bête dans
sa politique que Trump
on restera dans cette logique pour ou
contre Trump même si c'est Ron De Santis
par exemple
est un vrai conservateur contrairement à
Trump donc Trump a su répondre aux
attentes des conservateur notamment les
évangéliques blancs dont on n'a pas
parlé aujourd'hui mais qui pèse très
lourd dans ce vote parce que ce sont eux
qui vont voter pour un sherbrooker et la
religion est très importante en Géorgie
on en a pas parlé on n'a pas eu le temps
il y a un révérend voilà mais on accuse
chrétiens selon les le dogme
actuel de des évangéliques blancs il est
trop progressiste il est trop
progressiste
et le gouverneur Rome De Santis c'est un
vrai conservateur suffit de voir les
lois qu'il a réussi à faire passer en
Floride et je dirais que c'est ça va
être enfin si jamais il devait être élu
en 2024 ce serait un programme encore
plus conservateur sans doute que celui
d'autres
et donc il va œuvrer dans ce
sensateurs à la Cour suprême quelque
part il a fait le job aussi je pense
moins efficace si elle était plus
concentré sur le job et si elle était un
peu plus discipliné ça ferait un
candidat dangereux Gérald Olivier ou pas
la démocrates
c'est bien évident c'est d'ailleurs les
républicains donc conscience et c'est
d'ailleurs pourquoi l'annonce de la
candidature par Donald Trump n'a
absolument pas déclenché de vagues de
soutien Donald Trump et on a au
contraire le sentiment au sein du parti
républicain qu'il est en train d'être
lâché il avait déjà commencé à être
lâché par un certain nombre de soutiens
financiers et on voit que ça continue
donc on verra ce qui se passera demain
avec le résultat de la Géorgie mais il y
a au sein du camp républicain
aujourd'hui une volonté de dépasser
Trump de aller dans l'après Trump
justement parce que le trumpisme va lui
survivre à travers quelqu'un comme comme
De Santis ce qui le rendrait dangereux
pour les démocrates bien entendu Sonic
le mot de la oui vous êtes d'accord avec
ce qui vient d'être dit ce qu'a dit
Charles-Olivier oui plus ou moins plus
ou moins jusque jusque que que Trump a
dans un une situation complément
illogique il est homme il est le
président de certaines manières
sortant mais il est aussi le rabbitical
sortant mais il était aussi l'insurgé
alors il sera dans un position
absolument bizarre de de mener une
campagne contre les classiques de son
propre parti en tant qu'insurgé et
ex-président ce qui est
presque inédite dans l'histoire de
l'Amérique c'est vraiment extraordinaire
et je ne sais pas s'il est perdant s'il
est perdant et s'il est perdant dans les
primaires ce n'est pas sûr qu'il va
appuyer la candidature du gagnant si
c'est dit de santé ou quelqu'un d'autre
il pourrait faire 3e partie il pourrait
lancer une campagne de troisième partie
voilà un certain nombre de scénarios
c'est toujours passionnant merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous John Rick
McArthur agnestroyer elle a une Merci à
VOUS Gérald Olivier en Géorgie entre
warnak et Walker donc ça s'annonce serré
les deux candidats sont au coude et les
résultats définitifs pourraient
d'ailleurs ne pas être connu avant
quelques jours donc patience merci de
nous avoir suivi reste avec nous sur
France 24
[Musique]